What are some of the things
that when you say
you were rushed,
that if you could talk to
yourself, past Winnie,
that's going through this,
like what are some
of the things
that you learned from it
that you would be like,
hey, it's okay?
In this regard,
it would just be
take your time
with not rushing
and getting the product out.
Like the app wasn't ready.
You know, I wish
I had done
the whole waitlist thing.
I wish I'd done more pre-marketing,
but I was still
just so scared.
What was that catalyst point?
Now you've created a brand,
you're finding some success,
and you're like,
you know what,
I see another edge
in this market.
I'm going to go for it.
You know, I've been using
Polymarket for like two years
and just not seeing those markets
that I had an edge in.
I've grown up so natively
hosting and like
understanding internet culture
as it is,
like very media literate that way.
And I'm like,
that's a skill
that I have
that I'm not able to leverage.
I don't understand American politics.
Like why would I
just burn cash
spending on markets
that I don't understand,
and why not build markets
that I do understand?